hi I'm will and this is Tabata Tabata is
an high-intensity interval training
protocol that our professor in Japan
came up with in 1996 he created the 20
seconds of work 10 seconds of rest over
8 rounds lada can incorporate anything
across the board you can do with push-up
about a burpies about a sit-up what
CrossFit is done is they've taken the
tabata a timing protocol and taking it
into their bag of tricks Oh what do we
have we have 4 minutes what can we do
where can we increase this athletes
aerobic activity and actually it will
increase your anaerobic activity as well
because we'll throw in weighted
activities this is your at-home two
bought a core workout so run me through
this here what exactly we're going to be
working on targeting etc we're going to
target the core we're going to target
all aspects of the core so we're going
to start with we're gonna sandwich our
Tabata workout with a one-minute plank
hold so do a plank at the beginning to
buy in for the chance to do the workout
you're going to do the workout and then
at the end you're gonna do another plank
hold for one minute we'll call it the
cash out so you buy a nine eight and
cash no yeah alright so the first thing
is the plank from head to toe in a nice
sturdy position if you notice from my
shoulders all the way to my feet is a
straight line I'm going to hold that for
one minute and then we'll begin that's
about a exercises the first exercise
we're going to use this AB mat if you
look the AB mat shaped like your back so
you're gonna sit here right your lower
back sits here your upper back if you
don't have one of these can you use a
pillow or you can use a towel yeah it's
gonna set this behind your back we're
going to do plate to overhead we're
going to take the 25 pound plate set up
for your sit-up push it overhead gonna
go all the way back touch the ground
swing it up all the way up okay stays
overhead so we're not pulling anywhere
forward staying overhead down
overhead up or so you're still you know
when you come it up it never never
leaves this this way basically exactly
the second move is the Superman exactly
so you're gonna go up down up
down for how long 20 seconds so we're
gonna do 20 say 40 seconds 10 second
arrest they got you the next one is the
half Burpee okay so the demo is I'm
gonna put my hands on the ground shoot
my feet back and then pop them right
back forward clash I'll go to all the
way to the ground now going all the way
to ground last move is flutter kicks
back on your back mm-hmm here set up
squeeze my abs so my lower back is
hitting into the floor okay lift my feet
up baby kicks if you want to make this
more difficult you can put your hands
over your head I don't know about making
a mess at this point but I'll give it a
shot
I'm buying in here buying in all right
one full minute you dreamy way to one go
see I like this exercise for the first
10 or 15 seconds good you made it
through one minute now we'll start with
the tabata okay so weight in hand he's
bent feet flat yep
and three two one go down and all the
way up good try to come up all the way
together there we go
he's a plate right over your head that's
it
it's a lot of weight and rest all right
yes we can so I guess rest and into
Superman fly like a bird in three two
one go
good good mixer you're concentrating
kind of here and squeezing your butt and
three two one ten seconds rest now we
have the half burpees three two one go
to one rest ten seconds on to flutter
kicks oh yeah you never want to do large
scissor kicks that's going to target
something completely different
three two one
rep that's halfway through it's about a
cycle gotcha how we repeat that you
repeat that again and then sandwich that
one minute blankly yes sir all right
okay so to recap
that's our Tabata core workout we start
off with a one-minute plank since I
can't arrest then you go into 20 seconds
of AB mat sit-ups if you don't have an
AB mat again you can use a towel you
said folded over ten seconds to rest 20
seconds to Superman 10 seconds to rest
20 seconds of half burpees 10 seconds
arrest 20 seconds of flutter kicks
repeat that twice finish off with
another 1 minute plank that's how you do
it
instead of it preciate it make sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
other fighting weight episodes
you